Hello and welcome. This is active guest
room 52.1. On August 10, 2023,
we have Ahmed Elsaid, Alexander Ororbia
and Travis Desel. Ahmed is going to give
a presentation and following we will
have some reflections and discussions.
So thank you all for joining and Ahmed
to you for the presentation.
Okay, thanks so much for having me.
Today I'm going to discuss the
methods that we came up to solve new
art, texture, search and neuralvolution
problems. The methods that are ant
colony optimization based solutions.
So as the title here is mentioning,
ant colony optimization for neural text
research and neurovolution. This work is
collaboration between me, my previous
advisor, Dr. Travis Desel, and my co
advisor Dr. Alexander Auroravian.
I'm currently an assistant professor in
University of North Carolina,
wilmington.
And moving on to the next slide. So as
an overview, the things that I'm going
to discuss today, I'll try to give
Bird Eyes view for what is
neurovolution, why we what, why we
need it. And from there, I'll just try
to discuss our methods that
is based on end calling optimization
which is called N based neurotropology
search or ants for short. And after that
I will discuss how we advanced with this
idea by introducing
continuous ants or cans for short,
which could spread off the discrete
search space and replace it with a
continuous search space. And after that
I'm going to also say what we did with
the three dimensions and the continuous
ants to have back propagation free cans.
And later I will discuss three of the
points that we are considering for
future work.
So in the machine learning
learn, as the neural network
structures got deeper and deeper,
people were trying to optimize the
structures to have better performance.
And people in different realms or
different problem domain used
to borrow the best performing
architectures or structures and try to
modify a little bit to work for their
problem. And they try to tweak some of
the features of the structure and
compare these different tweaks. And then
they say that we found the best
performing structure. But to actually
find an absolute optimum structure
concerning that solution, it would be an
NP hard problem because to reach that
solution, they had to try
all the combinations of the different
structural elements, right?
Because we have massive structures
in these deep neural networks,
it could be an NPR problem because we
don't have computational power or enough
time to actually train
and test all these structures, all these
structures constructed from these
different combinations of structure
elements. So the alternative way to do
this is to actually try to apply a
meteoristic method to convert
to a near to upper solution that is much
better than not optimizing the structure
or relying on kind of like a random
search, right? A random search can get
us better performing neural network,
but it's not going to give us a near
to optimal solution or to converge to a
near to optimal solution.
So a minoristic method would give us an
automated method and
also would converge to optimum structure
new to optimum solution to this
structure problem.
So the way that people approached Nas
was by trying to mimic how optimization
is done in nature, right? So the
first way they thought of it was trying
to mimic how living organisms
evolve in nature using genetic
based algorithm like the Darwinian
Genetic Evolution.
It started with Neat,
it's a short for Neuralution
of Augmenting topologies and
it relied on genetic algorithms where
also that concept also applied
in most of the Nas and Neural evolution
methods and Exam is one of them.
Travis came up with this method and
it became one of the state of the art
methods in Nas.
So in such methods we tried
to again mimic genetic evolution by
introducing new structural elements or
removing structural elements or altering
the structure through the evolution
process, through the evolution
iterations and through the evolution
generations. So we can apply mutations
by splitting edges or adding
edges or disabling edges,
and we disable edges or disable some
structure elements so that we don't lose
that component, so that we can later on
use it. Kind of like a dormant gene in
a genome, right? So that it can appear
in later generations. Not to get rid of.
Totally. So in mutations we can disable
edges, we can enable them in later
generations. If we found that we want to
try this option,
we can also add recurrent edges or
remove or enable or disable
recurrent edges. We can split nodes, we
can take some of the nodes in a previous
generation and we can just
split it to two nodes and then take the
edges connected to that node and
try to divide it between the nodes that
was generated from the previous node in
the previous generation.
Also we can add nodes to
the structure. So all of these are part
of the mutation process. In the genetic
process we can also disable a node if
we want to try to just get rid of one of
the nodes and disabling a node. Or
multiple nodes will also disable the
edges connected to that node beside
mutations. The other side of a
genetic process is to do crossovers
where we have two of the best
performance population meet
together to bring an offspring and the
offspring will have collection of the
characteristics coming from their
parents. So it will take some of the
characteristics from that parent, some
other characteristics from the other
parent, hoping that this would give us a
better performing neural network or
better performing generation.
So the main problem sorry,
so the main problem with genetic
based algorithms is that they start with
minimal structures like we can see
there, meaning that inputs and outputs
and starting from the optimization with
this minimal search space can trap
the method in a local minima through the
optimization process. So we were
thinking how to get rid of this obstacle
by having a bigger or larger search
space to start with, and then we can
sample some solutions from that large
surf space. And we were looking around
and we concerned end calling
optimization, and I will say why, but
I'll try to introduce the method first.
So, the method was first introduced as
graphic optimization method, graph
optimization method, sorry. It was
introduced in mid 90s by Marco DeRego.
Marco DeRego applied this method on
a travel salesman's problem. And the
problem is mainly about a travel
salesman who wants to visit a number of
cities in a country using the shortest
staff and considering this problem. If
we have different number, if the number
of cities grows, then the permutations
of these numbers of these cities that we
have to consider to find the optimal
solution. If this number of cities
grows, then we will end up having an NPR
problem because we won't have enough
time or computational power to have
this exclusive solution done
or this exclusive search done.
So, from his observations
to answer in nature, he found
that he can apply how they forage to
find food in nature and
then take this concept, this
observation, and apply it in an
algorithm to find the optimum path that
leads from one point and to visit
all the cities in the shortest path.
So this observation,
this slide and the coming slides will
just try to give us a picture
of how hence forage
in nature to find food and then how
Marcus Rigor took that concept to apply
it in the travel systems problem.
So, ants observers
found that ants go out from their nest
to find food and
they try different directions, right?
And when they find food, eventually find
food, they will take some of that food
and then they will go back to their nest
and in the way back, they will deposit
some other substance, cholophone.
So they deposit that substance so that
they communicate that path to the food
resource with the other ants. So
actually, other ants do exploit this
other substance, and when they sense it,
they follow the path that the first ant
took from the food resource to the nest,
hoping that they will find food at the
end of that path. When they actually
find food at the end of the path, they
will take some of the food and do the
same thing. They will deposit some
morpher mole on the same path, making it
more appealing to other ants to take it,
so that they can bring more food to the
nest. So this process
shows us the exploitation behavior of
ants. But again, from time
to time, ants also try to exploit some
other food resources, potential food
resources, and they kind of resist
following the hormone traces,
and they try to go away and find some
new food resources for the nest.
So the ants are not only exploiters,
they're also explorers and these two
concepts were used by Marco Derago
to kind of like balance the search
for the better or faster path between
the cities for the travel sales
management problem.
The third thing that we observed also in
how I spoke in nature is that the older
substance, the pheromone, also
evaporates. So whenever a path to
a food resource is not appealing anymore
or the food resources are excluded, no
more ants will take that path or when
they take it and reach their food
resources that is exposed, they will not
take the same path to the nest again.
They will try to wonder and to find more
new food resources. And because they not
going that path again and not depositing
any pheromone on that path, the
pheromone will eventually evaporate and
disappears and making it less and less
appearing for other ants to take.
So that's
what Marco DeRego was looking at when he
thought of the travel salesman's
problem. He applied that
for the travel salesman's problem by
making one agent try these
different paths and then comparing
through each iteration. So that agent
will take a path between the cities,
right? And then it will compare the
length of that path to the previous
experience with other paths and if it's
shorter, it will try to deposit hormones
on the segments of that path. And
eventually he was hoping, and he was
right about what he was hoping. He was
hoping that eventually the
shorter path, shorter segments that give
the ultimate shorter path has
more and more hormone deposits making it
more and more appealing for the agent to
take it through the iterations.
So we thought about this concept
and we thought that it's very appealing
to apply it for an Nas problem because
Drago's solution was applied for a graph
optimization problem and neural networks
are in their sense direction graphs.
So we also considered endcon
optimization because it's full torrent,
decentralized and scalable and it's also
easily traceable going
back to being decentralized.
It made this method
a perfect candidate for a pal and high
performance computing solution which
will eventually accelerate the
optimization problem. I think.
In the next slide, after the next one,
I will discuss how we exploited or use
this characteristic of anonym
optimization to accelerate the solution
that we came up with or the method that
we came up with, which is ants and cans.
So this scheme, or the scheme of
ants applying ants or ant
collectimization in neural
architecture search is depicted or
illustrated in this flowchart.
So we start off with a massive search
space expressed in
superstructure which expresses
or embodies a
neural network that is massively
connected, meaning that each node in
that superstructure is connected with
the other nodes through edges and
recurrent edges, backwards and forward
and backward recurrent edges.
And then we let a number of agents
swarm over the structure from an
input node to an output node. So each
one of these agents will pick an input
node and then it wanders from that node
through the connection recurrent edges
and recurrent edges and
between the nodes and between the hidden
layers till it gets and picks one of the
output nodes. And then we take all these
paths of the different agents, and we
put them together to form a structure,
neural network structure. And we take
that structure and train it and test it
and then compare its performance to a
population of best performing neural
networks, best performance structures.
And if it's better than the worst in the
population, then we reward the path that
the ants took, the agents took over in
the superstructure, reward with hormone
so that it makes these paths appealing
for later iterations through the
evolution process or the optimization
process. That's if the generated
structure is best than the worst in the
population, if not, if it actually was
worse than the worst in the population,
then we discard that structure or
that neural network, and we don't reward
Any of the path that ants took. And also
the thermo evaporation will help us get
rid of the pheromones that were
deposited on the edges that are not
giving us better and better structures.
And again, because the M colony is
decentralized we exploited this by
having an asynchronous solution or
asynchronous evolution. We had a
main process that took care of
generating the new structures and also
updating the population the best
performing structures and updating the
hormone on the superstructure. So the
main process will generate structures
and send them to worker processes. The
worker processes will train and test the
neural network on the data that we have
for the problem and then send the
results back or the fitness of the
neural network to the main process. And
based on that fitness the main process
will either discard it or we'll
take this fitness and compare it to the
best performing in the population. If
it's better than the worst it will
reward the path that ends took on the
superstructure by depositing more
hormone. Or if it's worse than the worst
in the population, we'll just start it
and it will keep generating new
structures and sending them to processes
because the training which relies
on that propagation is the most
computationally expensive part in this
process. If we have a number of worker
processes that can work in parallel to
train and evaluate these neural
networks, these new structures we can
speed up the process, right by training
and evaluating different structures at
the same time in parallel in an
asynchronous evolution scheme.
This is an animation but it's not
working in this version of the slides
because we're using a PDF but it's
mainly a structure where you'll see
edges or connections between these nodes
fading or having darker
colors based on the pheromone values
through the iterations. So each frame in
this animation is kind of an update for
the pheromone value of the edges
based on the performance of the version
of the neural network that were
generated by the agents when they
swarmed from the start node taking one
of the input nodes in the middle layer
and then from there going to one of the
hidden layers in this one hidden layer
that we have here. And from there going
to the output.
So that was the concept of applying ACO
and con optimization in and
this now I'm going to talk about the
actual method that we came up with.
So it's more generic and more powerful
neural texture search method. More
comprehensive if I may say that we
opted to apply the methods on
recurrent neural networks because they
tend to be potentially larger than other
neural networks structures because of
their recurrent connections. So we
thought that if we started this problem
though the method or the concept applies
to any neural network but applying it to
recurrent neural networks made it more
appealing challenge for measuring
the performance of the method that we
thought of. So this
slide in the common slide will discuss
the different heuristics of the methods
of ants. The first heuristic is
superstructure itself and as I mentioned
before it's a massive search space as
massive as possible to be handled with
the machine or the hardware that we're
working on. The superstructure consists
of a neural network that is massively
connected meaning that every node in the
structure is connected to the other
nodes via or through edges. Forward
edges and recurrent edges. Backward
forward recurrent edges and backward
recurrent edges. This simple structure
that we have here represents one of just
the concept of the superstructure that
we apply in ants. Here we have
three input nodes, three hidden layers
each have three nodes and one output
node in the output layer. And we are
just showing one node connected to the
other nodes through edges which are the
ones representing green forward
recurrent sorry, the edges
are the one in gray and then forward
recurrent and backward recurrent in the
green and in the red. And the concept of
recurrent edges might be a little bit
confusing if we look at it in this
example because how can an edge be
recurrent coming in and out from the
same node, the nodes in the same
timestamp but this structure might make
it more clear. So here we
have structure that is pretty
much similar to the one we saw before.
But here we have three input nodes, two
hin layers still three hin layers each
have three nodes and then alpha layer
have two nodes and then we have also
three time steps. The current time step
t zero and the previous time step t
minus one, the one before that t minus
two edges here are illustrated
using the solid black lines.
Of course these edges are present in the
current time step that is going to
propagate through the neural network.
Then the current connections. These ones
are going to bring information or
provide information from the previous
time steps, the previous inputs or
previous data that was fired to the
nodes in the previous time steps. And
these recurrent edges are depicted here
in red and orange. The forward ones are
depicted in red and orange. The reds are
coming from T minus one and the oranges
are coming from T minus two. And the
backward current edges are the dot lines
in blue and green.
And we can see that they are going
backwards. So they go backward
to backward layers.
But because they are recurrent, we can
do that because they process
information, they bring information that
already processed. So we don't have to
worry about propagating information back
through time or back through the
structure. But we can do that if it's
coming from previous time step.
The second heuristic in Ash is the
colony weight sharing we wanted to use.
So instead of Brandon initialized the
weights or the snapped weights and
generated neural networks,
we wanted to use the train weights to
initialize the weights of the newly
generated neural networks.
We did that by saving these neural
networks on the superstructure. We used
the last equation here
to do this update. So we balanced
between the weights that were saved
previously and the weights that are
coming from the trained or evaluated
neural networks. And we also used two
strategies to do this update. We used a
fixed parameter phi or
we left phi. That was the first
strategy. The second strategy was to get
phi by applying these two equations
which relies on the performance of the
neural network that was previously
generated sorry, the previously
generated and trained. So it relies on
the performance of the neural network
that was trained and validated or
tested. So if
the performance was good, then we will
let the weights of that neural
network to contribute more to
the initialization of the weights of
the newly generated RNS. If it's not
performing that well, then this equation
will not allow it to contribute that
much. The third meta heuristic
is multiple memory cells. So at
each node,
when an agent or an ant reach to a node
in the superstructure it will do a local
search to pick the type of
the neuron or the type of the node from
these three different types of memory
cells. So in the generated RNN,
the generated structure, the nodes in
the structure is not all the same. They
will be different based on the local
search that the
agent will do or the ant will do. At
each node they reach through their path
from the input to an output in the
superstructure.
The fourth mineristic is the multiple
ant species. So we applied different
species or came up with different
species. For the ants, the first species
was the ones that will traverse over the
edges, only the edges. So they will go
only forward through the
edges of the neural network of the
superstructure. And these ones are going
to define the number of nodes in the
generated structure. Also define the
types of the nodes in the
superstructure. And when they done with
their work, then the social or the
second species, the social ants,
will traverse between these nodes.
But they will use the recurrent edges
to move between these nodes. So they
will create the recurrent edges
for the newly generated RNN. And we have
two different species for these social
ants or two different subtypes
subspecies. One is the
forward social ends. These ones traverse
only over the forward kind
of connections. They go from the input
to the output but only over the forward
recurrent edges and then the backward
recurrent edges or the backward social
ends. These ones go from the output to
the input and they traverse over the
recurrent connections. The reason we
thought about these different species is
that we wanted to control the tendency
of the ants to wander around
in the superstructure exploiting the
convoluted mesh of recurrent
connections. So we wanted to control
that. So we came up with this strategy
so that we can just define the structure
using the explorer ants and then the
recurrent connections can be defined
after that using the social ants.
The fifth characteristic is the
regularization of formal basement.
Again, we wanted to give the ants in an
incentive to bring sparser
and also well performing neural
networks by just penalizing them
if they constructed denser or bigger
structures. So we added this
regularization term and formula
that updated the hormone value.
And as you see, the regularization term
relies on the performance. The data here
is the performance of the neural network
and it also relies on the size of the
structure.
The last, the 6th and last one is
jumping ants which is we want to
experiment with. If we let the ants
if we let the ants jump over the layers
when they move through the
superstructure if we let them jump over
these layers to construct the neural
networks compared to if we restrict
their movement to jump one layer at
a time. How would this end up
performance wise if they will give us
parser and well performing structures?
Or this jumping will hurt the
performance by giving us weaker
structures, weaker neural networks.
So.
We use a timespheres data that
belong to Coal Fire Power plant. We
divide the data to have 7200
records for training and testing and
here the plot shows that the data and we
can see that it's nonlinear and it's
acyclic and non seasonal. So it's a hard
problem for a non neural
network solution or a regression linear
regression solution. So the input
consists of twelve parameters. When we
were trying to predict only one
parameter the flame intensity
experiments covered all of the
heuristics of ants giving different
values for these different parameters.
The superstructures consist of twelve
input nodes. Three hidden layers each
have twelve nodes and one output node in
the output layer. The recurrent
connection span over three times steps
one, two and three times steps. In
total, the superstructure had 49 nodes,
924 edges and almost 3.5
thousand recurrent edges. So if you
unroll the structure over 72 time steps
in back propagation through time will
have about 352,000
nodes, about 6.5 million edges and
about 26 million recurring edges.
In the experiments, we also compared
performance of ants using the same data
set. We compared it to exam and neat.
So Exam is the state of the art in
neural texture search which is genetic
based method. We also
compared it to NEET because it's like a
benchmark in the neural revolution and
nas realm. And also we compared it
to fixed structures, unoptimized
structures that
had one and two and three hidden layers
and also different types of memory
based cells. The experiments
covered 1600 experiments to cover all
the combinations of the meta heuristics
of the heuristics of ants. Each one
of these experiments was repeated ten
times for statistical analysis.
Ants generated 2000 RNNs
for each experiment. Each trained for
ten epics. In total,
ants generated about generated train
and evaluated 32 million RNNs.
It took a month and 1000 CPUs
to finish the experiments.
The results that we got showed that of
course outperformed the unoptimized
structures and it also outperformed Neat
and then some of the combinations of
ends outperformed Exam. So Exam here
is the fourth from the left and we can
see that the mean absolute error for
some of the versions or the combinations
of ant heuristics outperformed
Exam.
So we tried to look to do some
statistical study for the
results we got from Ads. So we tried to
look at the top performing
neural networks coming in our results.
So we tried to look at the top ten,
2522 hundred and 55
hundred results and we look at the
contribution of these heuristics in
these best performing neural networks
or structures. We found that
these heuristics contributed effectively
in most of these results.
But the
thing that was really intriguing
for us or surprise us is that
we saw that the recurrent connections
disappeared in risk results because the
best performing neural networks didn't
have that much of recurrent connections.
That meant for us that the memory
based cells did the job for recurrent
information coming from previous time
steps. But we wanted to expand on
this later. So it's on our list
discussing on our future investigations.
So this is just a summary for the
achievements of Ans based on the results
that we got from our experiments.
So ANZ was the first meta method to
involve the core of ACO and column
optimization and recurring neural
networks. Nas or neural heuristics
to control ants tendency to wander
around superstructure. Exploiting
recurrent connection proved successful
because the regularization component
or the regularization heuristics give
us better results. Showing here in this
table and also the jumping
ants here gave us better performance
compared to non jumping ants.
And the
realization. Also,
the weight sharing strategy
also proved effective.
If we look at it, the results here
compared to if we don't apply weight
sharing.
So autopromyzing strategies are
generic so the strategies that we use
are generic enough to apply it for any
problem or solution, that is end colony
optimization based. The Vermont
deposition that the method that we came
up with is also Novalu, which wasn't
introduced in any previous literature.
And the performance of ants compared to
the other benchmark and state of the art
in the realm is also remarkable.
So going forward, we thought that ant
gave us a good result. But the main
drawback of Ans was the discrete search
space. So ans worked on
this massively connected massively
connected superstructure, but it's
massive gas, but it's still discrete.
Ants can move freely between these
nodes. They are forced to move over
between these nodes, over these
predefined connections, whether they
are forward edges or recurrent edges.
So we thought of
removing that continuous discrete search
space and replacing it with a continuous
search space. So we designed
a 3D search space where
the search space had like layers
representing the lag, the time lags.
And then ants can jump over between
these layers to give us the recurrent
connections. And on each of these
layers, ants will just give us the
nodes and the edges between the nodes.
So in this slide, in the coming slides,
we'll show an example of how ants move
in cans or continuous ant, or continuous
ends. So an agent or an ant
will just start by picking up one of the
layers that will move on. This is done
in a discrete fashion and once this is
done, it will then decide if it's going
to do an exploitation or exploration
movement. And in this example,
it decided to do an exploration
movement. So it will decide the angle
and the radius of its next allocation on
that layer. Once that's done,
it's going to go forward to that
location and then decides if it's going
to do an exploitation or if the next
move will be exploitation or exploration
move. And this example will be an
exploitation move. So it will try to
exploit the pheromone traces, the
hormone that was previously deposited by
other ants in the search space. So it
will use its sensing radius, that's
something that is previously defined for
each ant. And then it will find
the center of mass of the hormone
traces. And then when
it calculates that center of mass of the
hormone, it will consider it as its next
location and then it will move to that
spot. And then it will decide about if
its next move will be an exploitation
exploration move at each location before
it's deciding about the type of the
step. If it's exploitation exploration,
it will also decide if it's going to
stay at the same level at the same time
lag or jump to a next time lag.
If the jump or the movement is on the
same level,
if the movement is on the same level,
if the ants is doing an exploitation
movement it will only consider the
promontory that is ahead
of it because it can't move backwards on
the same time lag. Otherwise it will be
doing a backwards step which is not
allowed in neural networks.
But if it's going to another time
lag above layer then it's
going to do a recurrent edge.
Current edges can go back in time sorry,
back in the structure in the previous
layer. So now the end can
consider all the promote traces within
radius, the ones that are ahead of it
and the ones that are behind it. So in
this example he is going to consider in
this step is going to consider all the
promote traces within its sensing
radius, calculate the center of mass and
then consider it as its next position.
And it keep doing this till it reaches
to the proximity of the output node.
And once this is done, it will decide
which output node it will consider as
its final position in its path from an
input to the output. And then
other ends will do the same.
And then we'll have different paths from
some input and some output.
And then Cans will take these paths and
then try to condense the nodes so that
we don't have so much nodes that are
very close to each other. So the nodes
that are within certain proximity will
be clustered together using DB scan to
have less number of nodes. And then
the paths will be taken,
collected and put in a structure,
a neural network structure. And then
sent to a worker process to train and
test and then compare it to the
population, the best performing RNNs.
And the process will be almost the same
from this point will be almost the same
as ants once the structure is
constructed. And the training and
testing process will be the same as the
ones that we discussed in ants.
So this was also an animation which
shows how these tasks
are taken by the ants. Look from an
input to an output in the 3D space 3D
search space so ants,
if we look at ants, ants have only
eight tunable hyperparameters compared
to when comparing this to ants and XM,
it's half of the number of
hyperparameters in the other methods.
These hyperparameters are the number of
layers of the search space, the number
of time of lags, how many of them we
have in search space. Number of agents,
number of ants, which is similar to what
we have a similar hyperparameter in ants
the sensing radius of the agents or the
ants the agents probability to create a
new node which presents
the exploration instead of the
exploitation of the parameters or the
hormone back traces in the space.
Node condensation parameters
or factors the
variables that represent in the DB scan
are considered also hyperparameters in
cans for one updating parameter and for
one volatility parameter and these are
also present in ants and
ACO based problems solutions sorry
the experiments used three times years
different number of parameters and
different sizes. The results
showed that the
results that we got from Cans were very
competing with ants and Exam.
They weren't necessarily better,
but they competed. They weren't the same
level, but it also did
didn't do very well in one of the
database, the data sets. But that
was comparing the performance as the
mean absolute error, but comparing
Kent's results from the
sorry.
The size of the neural networks that we
got from Cairns, we saw that
Cain's structures were sparser,
so the performance was competing with
ants and exam. But the structures
compared to ants were much sparser,
similar to exam. The size
of the structures that we're getting
from Exam. Remember, exam is genetic
based, meaning that we start the
optimization process using the minimal
structure elements but
it was susceptible to local minimum
traps and Tense is
not susceptible to this problem. But it
also gave us smaller structures
with performances that were competing
with other methods. Exam and ants.
So the advantages of Cans is
that it has an unbalanced space compared
to ants compared the
results that came out were good compared
to ants and Exam. The tunable
hyperparameters are half of these in
Exam and ants and also it indirectly
encoded the neural topology to 3D thrash
spaces. So this is one of maybe
the contributions of important
contributions cans then
so far ants and Cans are solutions that
applied neural topology
architecture search meaning that they
did not optimize the synaptic parameters
of the neural networks during the
optimization process or during the
evolution process. So we
thought of actually making ends capable
of doing this as well. So to train the
neural network or optimize the synaptic
weights, the weights of the structure of
the neural networks during the
optimization process, the structural
optimization process. So we added a
fourth dimension to the search space
which we embedded the weights of
snapdragon parameters in
that map, these parameters
in that new dimension.
We also wanted the ants to be
self aware and try to evolve
themselves through the evolution
process so that they can adapt to
the changes or adapt themselves so that
they can give us better performance.
We want them to change their behavior,
their characteristics like the sensing
radius they had before, for example,
that can be a variable that can change
through the iteration thing and evolve
through the iterations. Each end can
change these characteristics as
the evolution goes on on progress based
on the performance of the neural
networks that they are generating.
So the advantage of
doing this was that it eliminated the
back propagation process which is the
most computationally expensive part in
the evolution process in the methods
that we use so far in exam ends and
Cans. So eliminating the back
propagation gave us much faster
evolution process.
The results we got I will discuss the
graph on the right hand side first which
discusses the fitness or the Ms main
absolute error of the results we got
from back propagation
free cans, the four dimension cans
compared to the normal cans, the back
propagation cans and ants. So the
results showed us that again
on a particular database that that
propagation cans and that propagation
free cans did quite a similar job
but they were both better than ants on
this particular database. But the
actually main contribution or the main
advantage of applying Cans shows up in
the graph on the left hand side.
Because we can see that if you compare
the results based on the time
of the evolution based on the evolution
time, we see that it
took much less time than the
back propagation version of cans and the
ants using these different
number of ants,
Also this graph shows how fast back
propagation precans compared to the
normal cans.
In this figure the curves and the dollar
lines shows the time that
back propagation free cans and cans took
to prepare or generate the neural
networks. We can see that back
propagation frequency took more time to
prepare or generate neural networks
compared to back propagation cans or the
normal cans. And that's because the
fourth dimension also has to evolve the
ants or the agents through the
iteration, so needs more time to do
that. But the
other two curves in dashed lines, here
are the lines that shows the amount of
time it took for the two methods to
train and validate the neural networks.
So backpropagation free cans doesn't
have to train the neural network doesn't
do backpropagation.
So you can see that the time it took is
in an order of magnitude less than the
back propagation version of camps. And
these sort of lines shows the cumulative
time took for both methods and of course
it shows that back propagation precances
took much much less time than the back
propagation precance took much less time
than the back propagation cans.
The future directions that we are future
points that we're concerning for sorry,
the points that we're concerning for
future work are to turn cans to a
complete continuous search space. So as
you saw,
the search space for Kents is not purely
continuous because the time lags are
represented by discrete layers. We want
to replace this with the continuous
dimension continuous layer representing
the time lag in RNNs. However,
this is a little bit challenging because
the time lags has to be known prior
to any optimization process because
other than that we will be mapping
the whole time series as time
lags and then picking the time lags from
them which is not feasible. So this is
the first point we're considering to
investigate for in future work. The
second one is to investigate this
finding that we found
in the results in ants where
the recurrent connections disappeared
from the best performing structures.
The theory that we have is that the
memory based cells replace these
connections, give us the information
that we need from the pastime steps so
that they were more effective, more
efficient in doing this compared to the
recycle connections. So we have to
expand on this and investigate it more.
The last thing we want to consider also,
this is one of the top things that we
want. These three points are the top on
our list. The third one is to actually
consider one of the concepts that was
coined in a book by Dr.
Deborah Gordon where she mentioned that
the living organism
in ants world are not the ants
themselves, but they are the colonies.
The colonies are the organisms that they
start, and they grow, and they interact
with the environment and the ecosystem.
They interact with other colonies, and
they die at some point. And the ants
themselves are not organisms. They are
the cells of these organisms, this
colony organisms. So we want to take
that concept and apply it in our methods
to have number of colonies living
together in parallel, evolving and
communicating with each other. And we
want to see if this would give us a
better performance, because, after all,
we're trying to mimic nature in the
solutions we're trying to investigate.
So with this, I'm done with my
presentation, and if you have any
questions.
All right. Awesome. Wow, what a great
presentation. How about Travis and
Alexander? Either of you which want to
go first, please feel free to give an
introduction and any primary remarks
that you have on that.
Okay. I can say something. I don't have
too much to add. I think Abdul Rahman
did a pretty good job going over the
core bits of the work. I'm Alex Rorbia.
I'm an assistant professor in computer
science, an affiliate professor
in psychology, and affiliate faculty in
computational neuroscience at the
Rochester Institute of Technology. And I
work on a lot of stuff, but primarily
predictive coding, active inference
variational, free energy, a lot of the
stuff that's actually of interest to
this. Yeah, and this was a particularly
interesting project for me because a
branch of my own research is working in
neurovolutionary methods or even just
nature inspired metahuristic
optimization. And when I got the
pleasure of working with Abdul Rahman
when he was a PhD student at Know,
we talked a lot about the ant colony
based optimization approaches, and I
encouraged him to look into sort of,
like, the origins and also try to
understand actually how physical ants
behave. So that was always fascinating
to me. I don't have too much to add in
terms of the technical parts. I think he
covered all the core results. The only
thing I like to think about. And I'm
actually more fascinated, too, to hear
from the active inference institute
their interest in the ant colony methods
and particularly what was interesting to
them. Because thinking about what does
ant colony optimization how do you view
it from an active inference perspective
is, I think, particularly interesting
and thinking. And I even had a thought,
I don't know if this was a question
among the audience's mind. Do the little
ant agents or the cant agents that run
and described what is
there a way to start to view them as a
multi agent system that's optimizing
some variational free energy quantity?
Because a lot of even Carl's work I
mean, I collaborate with him, sort of
touches into this area of, like, well,
what happens with collective
intelligence and societal organization?
And you can kind of look at free energy
from these very high level viewpoints
all the way down to fine grained
cellular activity. And so I'm actually
more curious to know Daniel and anyone
else in the active inferences who can
sort of explain their particular
interest in ant based optimization and
meta heuristic optimization. I'm curious
to know that. But there could be some
interesting viewpoints, like, what is
the free energy? I think the ants
themselves are very mean.
We have made them more intelligent. I
know Abdul Raman and I talked at length
about, well, what if we even made them,
for example, have, like, a reinforcement
learning control system? And you could
even imagine, well, now, what if the
cans themselves engage in
a form of active inference themselves?
What would that look like for the
system? And they are optimizing their
own free energy. Those are just fun
little thought experiments. We have
obviously not worked on them. At least
Abdul Rahman was never exposed by me to
that part of my world and biomimetic
intelligence. So those are my comments.
I'm not sure if they're particularly
helpful, but they're very general, and
I'm actually more curious to know from
the active inference institute, their
interest in it and where does that maybe
perhaps intersect? Or this is just like,
oh, we know interesting topics and yeah.
Thank you. Alexander. Travis, you want
to say hello and give any reflections on
the talk?
Sure, I'll come in. Hopefully you can
see me a little bit. My jungle here.
Hi, I'm Travis is Sell. I'm an associate
professor at RIT. I'm also the graduate
program director for a master's in data
science. So if any of you are interested
in any of this or data science, please
shoot me an email. No, I thought this
work was really very interesting in a
lot of ways while Abdul Rahman was
working on it. I think one of the
coolest parts about it is a popular
neuroevolution algorithm that came after
neat is called hyperneet, and it
transforms the discrete
search space of neural architecture
search into a continuous one. And it's
shown to be a pretty powerful method.
Well, this version of ant colony
optimization, the new one, does the same
thing. It makes the search space
continuous. But what I found was really
cool about it was that as opposed to
traditional ant colony optimization
where you have a graph and you just send
the ants along the edges of the graph
and you take the best paths and
construct a graph after it. Here the
ants are actually working like ants in
the real world where they'll move a
continuous amount of space, not just
from point A to point B and actually
dropping down pheromones. And it's more
like a real simulation of how ants would
move around in the real world. And we're
getting better results from it than some
of the older methods. So I think
that really made me kind of happy to see
that and thought it made it as very
interesting work.
That's awesome. Ahmed, want to add
anything or I'm happy to give a thought
on the answer and ask some questions
from the live chat. I'm good.
Travis, I think, covered all the things
that I wanted to say about,
I think just one thing that Alex
mentioned that we give higher
intelligence to the agent. This is
something that we discussed and I'm
pretty much open to that. I started
actually to think about it, but I didn't
implement anything yet. However, the
last thing that I discussed in the
future directions is something that I
actually started working on, but I
didn't start the experimentations yet.
So hopefully we will see something out
of that. Awesome.
Well, there's a ton of ways to go and
isn't that kind of one of the
fundamental questions like in an
interactive setting, either pure agent
stigma g interaction or multi agent,
but ultimately mediated through multiple
stigma g's with like reading and writing
and error correcting code. So in that
communication setting, I felt like the
work generalizes along multiple
dimensions that previously approaches
to multi agent just didn't have those
kinds of flexibilities like the
continuous time feature and several
other features. And I
guess with respect to the ants
themselves, I did five summers of field
work with ants in the USA Southwest in
Arizona and observed a lot of foraging
activity. So that problem
or that context or setting is really a
fun one and a pervasive one across any
kind of living system, anything that's
going to be active and living. So why
did you pursue foraging type algorithms
overall? And does this class
include the interaction based methods
with direct agent contacts that
Professor Gordon highlights in the Ant
Encounters book? Yeah,
I will try to respond to this, but I
just want to mention that the first
thought about this actually Travis
started this idea about using N colon
optimization and neural sector search by
applying this method in simpler neural
networks. Elman and Gordon neural
networks required neural networks and I
took the leap from there and started
working on my thesis, my PhD thesis.
So we thought about this idea. I think I
mentioned a little bit about why we used
an optimization in previous slide, but
just repeating that for the audience to
make sure that they got we thought about
this idea because Nko optimization was
applied as a graphic
solution, and we thought that why
not neural networks since they are
investments? Neural networks, they are
directed graphs. Neural networks are
directed graphs because the flow of
information goes from one direction to
another direction. So they are directed,
but they also graph because they are
nodes connected with edges. And our
ultimate aim or goal was to optimize the
structure by removing and adding
elements to it so that it gives us
better.
Awesome. And one way that Professor
Gordon and others have talked about that
bi directional learning relationship
between the computer science and the
math and the analytical formulations and
then the field work and the actual
behavior is because the thousands of
species of ants. They're working amidst
a huge range of ecologies with
all these different patterns of
regularities, all these different
resource distributions and foraging.
It's amazing how general it is. Yet it's
also just one of the functionalities
that need to occur in terms of these
even slower processes, like allocation
of tissue to faster processes,
even of response to alarm pheromone. So
it's like this one class of algorithms
clearly scales across from few.
Ultimately one some of these foraging
algorithms are lone foragers they don't
leave pheromone trails. So it's like
even the idea of leaving a single
positive pheromone or leaving but also
there's things models can do that ants
can't do, like the time travel,
pheromone, lossless perception, high
dimensional signaling profiles that
can't occur just with like finite
amounts of molecules. Now they are
just persisting on their path as active
agents within one generation with a
variational free energy at the
behavioral scale, then across
generations with that evolutionary
layer. And the relationships between the
neural network implementation and the
active inference model. They're kind of
like two ways of describing,
implementing. Yeah.
I'd be curious to hear any of your
thoughts on where you see active
inference coming into play or how do you
see ultimately similarities and
differences between neural network based
approaches and active inference based
approaches. Are they the same
complementary, overlapping.
Guys? Want to take this one?
I think this might be more of an Alex
question, to be honest. That's the test.
Well, yeah, I mean, if you want to keep
it on active inference. But I think,
Travis, you're going to need to tag in
when you want to get into the very
specifics of the actual ant colony
details because, again, I kind of see
the ant colony optimization from a more
global point of view. I would say so
to be mean this particular work. So that
way Abdul Rahman is not also completely
blindsided by your question, Daniel,
even though the name is in the institute
itself, this isn't an active inference.
You know, again, while there are
obviously, as you pointed out, lots of
interesting elements like, for example,
the fact that the ants when they conduct
their exploration along let's just think
about the recurrent networks and they're
figuring out what nodes and what as
Abdul Rahman explained the
superstructure, right as they iterate
across with their pheromone trails and
figure out what nodes I want to
recurrently, connect, feed, forward,
connect, skip, connect, so on and so
forth. You. Would say. Well, okay. What
these ants are doing is they're engaging
in epistemic foraging, which is a key
concept in active inference or idid. So
that way Abdulrahman and Travis are not
also left behind by a jargon epistemic
foraging and active inference. It's a
big general framework. It's like a
neurobiological process to RL. And
epistemic just refers to kind of like
the uncertainty Travis that you and I
work on. And the idea is it's saying,
well, OK, I want to understand my world.
And the more that I explore my world,
right, there will be things that
surprise me less. But if I encounter
some information that is really weird
when I build a generative world model or
a predictive world model, that's very
surprising, I should probably explore
that. And so, of course, I'm condensing
the concept down into sort of like the
exploration part of the explore exploit
trade off that I know, you know, but
that characterizes reinforcement
learning. So that's just what we mean
when we say epistemic or epistemic
foraging. And obviously, Abdul Rahman
foraging can be likened to what the ants
are doing, right? They're exploring
their environment. And so I guess with
that in mind. So that way everyone's
sort of on the same page here to get to
your question about the differences,
about how does this work versus your
typical neural based approaches to
active inference. And I would fall into
that category of, oh, I build neural
models, biological process models.
Those are very much focused, you could
say, at the individual level, at least
the ones that I am aware of. When you're
building, for example, even a back
propagation based, partially observable
Markov decision process in active
inference, that's like a single agent,
right? You're trying to build this
construct that is trying to balance the
epistemic quantity with its instrumental
term, which, by the way, another jargon
term for you, Abdul Rahman and Travis,
that's just like your reward signal or
your prior preference or a prior
distribution over goal states. And so
these agents sort of like deal with that
trade off, but at an individual agent
level. Now, again, I'm sure that there's
interpretations of these from other
perspectives, the ant based approach,
even though I would not argue per se
that this has at least an explicit form
or a connection, at least that Abdul
Rahman has made clear to active
inference. But the idea is that this is
like a multi agent approach to active
inference. And so the ants, when they
conduct their epistemic foraging, which
arguably is a very simple model,
each ant and of themselves is
essentially a bunch of coefficients and
some hard coded rules because their job
is essentially to work together with
their pheromone trails to figure out oh,
what parts of the superstructure are
useful. So I'd say that that's different
and it lends itself in some ways. Of
course, you can make the ants more
complicated and lose the benefit of I'm
just about to say you could massively
paralyze this. And this is one of the
key strengths that I think is natural.
In, for example, a lot of actually
nature inspired optimization algorithms
and ant colony optimization is one of
them. Is Abdul Rahman has been using
hundreds of CPUs, and you can put these
ants on their own individual processor,
and the communication that's occurring
across them as they exchange information
is through the pheromone trails.
There's an indirect mechanism, it's not
terribly complex to facilitate. And I'm
sure that there's even better ways to go
about doing asynchronous forms of
communication and further, further
optimize this. I know Travis and Travis
can add to this has done things on like,
citizen science and distributed
computing through volunteer computing
and how you can distribute this through
a massive global Asynchronous network.
So you can imagine adapting the ant form
sorry, the ant colony optimization
approach to some distributed, massively
distributed version of active inference,
where you essentially have to write down
that the variational free energy. And
I'm putting quotes around this because,
again, there is no concrete term written
in Raman's work because at least
we haven't viewed this from the active
inference perspective directly. Each ant
is optimizing its own variational free
energy, but then there's probably a
global quantity that sort of is related
as a function of those pheromone trails
in the individual ant agents. And then
of course with the exploitation term or
the instrumental or what is the reward
signal to give an RL term that's sort of
driven by the performance of the actual
agent on each candidate agent on the
task right of the ram. And you compute
like mean squared error when you're
doing time series prediction. So in some
sense we have built in a reward function
that we use and again, for those in the
active inference group here, you can use
the complete class theorem and look at
the prior preference of saying, oh,
well, the reward is actually technically
a prior preference, right? It's like a
log probability. So with that in mind,
you could squint at ant colony
optimization. And I guess the big
benefit comes from that massive
parallelization that you wouldn't
actually very easily, if at all, get
with our single agent neural based
approaches. And that might be an
interesting place to build on and I'll
stop rambling at this point. I'm not
sure if that was helpful.
That was awesome. Even earlier today,
Chris Fields in the Physics as
information processing course was
talking about the classical information
inscribed on the blanket, which is like
the pheromone perception and deposition,
pheromone modification and perception
sense making an action which we can
associate with the nest mate cognitive
system. So then there could be as simple
as a pass through for the nest mate,
could be any arbitrary relationship
described with a blanket, simple nest
mate, sophisticated nest mate, like
another level of time series modeling,
whereas there's the environmental time
series modeling and that's just in the
ants. And then the fourth
dimension is like that quantum rotation
which goes from the lower dimensional
classical stigmagic screen into the
quantum informational space. And so
that's one of the discussions ongoing in
Actimf right now is about well,
previous approaches to connect quantum
formalisms to macro,
let's just say neural phenomena based it
upon the plausibility of like a
molecular electronic bubbling up.
Whereas just with research from decision
making and statistics and just
multiperspectival modeling and all the
issues associated with the physicality
of information transfer, the finiteness
of it, the quantum formalism becomes
useful just by itself with or without
reliance on some other electronic
phenomena. So it's just a lot of very
interesting connections like having the
degrees of freedom on the blanket which
could be noiseless and four bits or it
could be noisy with this really specific
thing. But in Silico you get to play
it from both sides and scale things up
and down and do these meta heuristics on
top of that arbitrary space could be
really simple for learning, or it could
be however much. And then just like the
ant colony algorithm is ultimately
federated through embodiment, that
property makes it a really useful
candidate for biomimicry. So a lot of
times when people think about collective
behavior, they're thinking about like
the flock of birds and the school of
fish and those are of course collective
systems and collective behavioral and
all these kinds of complex systems
properties can be studied in that type
of system. But it is also neglecting
at least an analytical degree of freedom
with the stigma g. So that really
opens up both the quantum and the
classical information or both niche
modification and behavioral and
cognitive modeling. So just to add on
because I think and then also what the
node is could even be heterogeneous or
unknown or fit in different ways or fix
through design processes. So just like
the ant colonies are flexible, enabling
them to live in all kinds of places,
make all these kinds of nested decisions
that interact with each other, that
flexibility is just like the tip of the
iceberg, of what we could even just
describe, because there would always be
real environments we hadn't yet tried
with ant colonies. So we really would
never know the full extent of all the
repertoire and the dynamics of the ant
system. But then we can just abduct
into new mathematical statistical
distributional frameworks, pull back to
different levels of the learning and the
meta learning process and just start
there. And then almost ironically,
or maybe the opposite of that, it.
Could be applied to ant colony video
data or movement data or foraging
activity itself. But it kind of
takes inspiration and develops in
parallel or in conversation. So it's not
like bound to what real ants can do. Or
you could constrain it so that there are
properties that real ants have, like
they can only interact within this
certain way or there really are only
this many pheromones do model
comparison. So it's a lot of degrees of
freedom. I feel like you all are opening
up with the ant collie modeling. And
also one of the challenging pieces of
multi agent simulation is kind of like
the open endedness with the design
space. So then it's very hard for
even creative ideas like sometimes to
find the right compute resources that
obviously are still even needed for what
he discovered with the analysis.
Here I'll ask a question from Bert. In
the to before we move on to that, I just
want to clarify just so make sure that I
got the right term and certainly Abdul
Rahman and Travis might want to look it
up is when you were saying blanket, you
were referring to a Markov blanket,
correct? Yes. So the technical
definition of Markov blanket is when you
have a Bayesian graph where nodes are
the variables and edges are
relationships amongst these variables.
For any given node of interest, we'll
just call it internal states. So these
are not features of the world. It's not
tagged onto some tissue of a real nest
mate in the world. This is something
that's tagged onto or like a perspective
we could take on any node in a Bayes
graph and then all the nodes that
insulate it and the co parents are known
as the blanket in the sense that it's
like one layer insulator. And there's a
lot of more discussion on it and the
philosophical implications and all these
generalizations of that. But broadly,
the Markov blanket is just the inbound
dependencies which we associate with
sense making and perception learning
attention and then the outgoing
dependencies for the agent which we
associate with action influence in
some downstream pointing way. Thank you.
I just wanted to clarify that because I
don't think Abdul Rahman and Travis
might be familiar just with that
terminology. It's very know, very active
inferency kind of jargon. So I wanted to
make sure that they got that from the
physics point of thanks. Yeah, totally
great point. And ask a question now
from Bert. So Bert says.
Very impressive. Solving generative
models with more generative models
sounds very promising. What about
replacing ants with convolutions?
Talking about like a meta learning
algorithm, like having a neural network
that learns how to optimize other neural
networks?
Yeah, this concept, I think is
introduced at some point in machine
learning learn. But we wanted to apply
for nature based method
that mimics like the Mother Nature,
which is nature is the
most efficient optimization evolution
system. So looking at the results that
are there in nature applying nature
based methods they were superior to any
other method. And the results we got
also which just pointed that out that we
saw good performance coming out from
these results from our results and the
previous results from other methods as
well. Hop in here a little bit
too. In the case of neural architecture
search there's kind of a couple of
classes of approaches. One is
constructive, so kind of like where you
build larger and larger networks and try
and keep your network size minimal to
try and find your optimal solution.
Other types of neural architecture
search approaches use like a
superstructure and this is kind of how
the earlier iterations of this were
where you have a bound of your search
space and you try and find the optimal
network within that bound. So one is
like trying to build things from the
ground up and the other one is trying to
trim down a big network to a small
network. As to your question about
convolutions, there's been
a fair bit of research lately in what's
called graph based neural networks which
can use convolutions over like a
discrete graph search space and can
potentially produce other graphs. And I
believe there's been some neural
architecture search work using this.
But one of the main and I think cool
things about the approach here, which is
different from those is if even if you
have a graph based neural network and
you have your search base defined as
some kind of matrix where things are off
and on depending on which nodes are
connected to each other. You have a
fixed search space which may not be big
enough or it might not be the correct
search space for this neural
architecture search problem where this
method here is all continuous. Right?
So within this continuous search space
it gives the algorithm a lot of freedom,
maybe too much freedom but a really open
ended way of generating a wide variety
of neural architectures which if you
preconstrain your algorithm to work
within a fixed discrete superstructure
you may not even find them because
they're not even a possibility.
So that's one of the reasons we didn't
go that route. But there are graph based
neural architecture search algorithms
out there where basically you take the
architecture as a graph, you train a
neural network to spit out another graph
that it might think is better and those
use convolutions. Sometimes that helps.
That's awesome. So convolution sounds
like yes. And one thought on that is
yes, the ants solve all these incredible
patterns and kind of do amazing
things amidst informational and physical
limitations like we all do having
the ants be able to just
make trade offs within a task space
and then have a dial as modelers to
make that task space. Kind of like
touching the pheromone distribution or
metacognitive ants or something
emulating essentially that. And for
example, the active inference forward
looking and thinking through other minds
that there could be a kind of cognitive
colony. So then that enables in silico
total thought, experiment colonies and
through data driven processes also
kind of keep continuity with that model,
perhaps literally continuity with the
model and then connect it to empirical,
which is something that is
very hard for agent based modeling
which, as you kind of pointed to, often
sets certain fixed axes, performs like
asweep looks at one mechanism,
doesn't look at all these possible
mechanisms of learning and intra and
intergenerational and all these time
effects. So how do you see this
being used in different research or
application domains?
Well,
the main use case that we're thinking of
was neural architecture search to
apply it for other domains other than
neural architecture. We didn't figure
out that yet. I think Alex can explain
on that. I can hop in a little bit mean.
So basically this type of algorithm, if
you need to generate graphs and you
don't necessarily have a fixed structure
for that graph and when I say graph, I
mean like a computer science graph where
you have nodes in a different so pretty
much anything involving graph
construction. I think these types of
methods work. Neural networks kind of
under the hood can be represented as
graphs and usually are. So I think we're
using it for neural networks because
it's really popular but there's other
algorithms out there like the
traditional traveling salesman, there's
like routing problems, all that, any
type of stuff where you might need to
generate a graph in a smart way to
do that. To your other point though, I
think what's really cool here and I
don't want to steal Alto Robin's
thunder, but his last point on future
direction is while a particular version
of this ant colony optimization search
is running to find an optimal neural
network, a colony has fixed parameters
that it operates within. But if you
think of the colony as an organism as
opposed to the ants being an organism,
you can evolve colonies that optimize
how the ants themselves act.
So you can have evolving colonies that
in a smaller sense also evolve or
optimize what they're doing within their
prescripted parameters for the agents
they're generating. So you can have like
a meta meta.
It's awesome. I mean the evolutionary
account of a why question for ant
behavior today, one part of that answer
is like because colonies that couldn't
under that regularity or constraint
survive. We've had a long, long time to
wipe those off the table. And so every
biological system has to have that kind
of multiscale ordering.
In 2021 we made the active imper ants
paper which was modified from an
epistemic foraging visual attention task
about scanning around and then learning
a cicade policy that had to do with
epistemic foraging but not leaving a
trace. And then the main modification to
bring that active inference epistemic
visual foraging model into the active
inference ant setting was to add a
pheromone rule, just like you described,
even though, of course, again, that's
not the only pheromone rule, but that's
just the most simple pheromone rule that
we can generalize from, as you
definitely have. And there are just many
emerging ways of modeling those
multiscale active inference models. So
composing across layers, which we might
associate more with the kind of
laterality of things that happen through
interactions. And then also, as Mike
Levin shows, with kind of the time
diamond systems that have a memory
retention component of some shape,
cognitive shape, and then a protention
awareness or agency or other attributes
you can use to describe that. And that's
a statistically amenable way to describe
things. And then there's a variety of
implementations on a given statistical
problem, or like Federated Compute
architecture, it might be the case that
you're not running the pure matrix
multiplications that are shown in the
early MATLAB code of active inference.
Different components of machine learning
systems might be kind of composed
together, also ways kind of abiding by
those patterns of communication. But
then there's a level of abstraction that
we can still describe, but it doesn't
mean active inference is going to be
kind of causing it. So that's what gives
a lot of flexibility. And it's really
cool that through your background,
Alexander and work and these kinds of
collaborations that like the active
inference perspective on multi agent
modeling with all these other views can
at least come together comparatively.
And then that is going to, I think, be
quite an interesting interchange to
apply this entire tissue
type or colony type thinking
above and within the models. Just a lot
of degrees of freedom, like you said,
could be too. And I think there's
different ways too, I think depends on
how you want to take the ant metaphor.
And again, it's kind of interesting,
some of the questions or comments that
you're making, Daniel, and some from the
audience about how does this think
about it from a cognitive point of view.
I mean, I do work in cognitive
architectures, of course, again, kind of
from the whole single agent or single
entity and modeling a single brain in
its different regions. But I think if
you take a nature inspired
optimization approach like the ant
metaphor that Abdel Rahman latched
onto, and that's sort of like the way in
which he formalizes how takes a
principle of how ants interact with
their world, interact with each other,
and then mathematically model those
particular concepts step by step. And I
think if you bend the metaphor and say,
well, okay, could the ant colony
metaphor apply to multi human agent
systems, right, or other entities?
Does the ant necessarily can it be
generalized beyond the physical creature
upon which Abdul Rahman based his
initial metaphor? And that's an
interesting philosophical kind of take
to it. And then how do you apply that
to, let's say, building a multi agent
cognitive system. And then, of course,
as Travis was discussing with you and
you were mentioning metacognition know,
you could think of ant colonies, of ant
colonies, but you could even replace the
word ant and just say, well, we have
clusters of intelligent agents,
or whatever degree of modeling we're
doing. Because again, I do want to
emphasize that at least the cans and
ants agents that I have worked with in
the context of the Raman, they are not
each and of themselves, even, I would
argue, if nothing else, a very extremely
simplified generative model or a very
simple control system. There's no neural
network under each one because then
you'd have to simulate computationally
each one of these ants within the
framework. So I think there's always
that practical machine learning kind of
viewpoint of, well, there's always how
do you simulate that? And Alderam is
working with CPUs. It's not like he has
an army of GPUs to replace them with
convolutional networks. Again, if you
had the resources, this would be
awesome. But expense and money is
another constraint on this planet. But I
think there's interesting views and
interesting directions one could go by
taking inspiration from the ant metaphor
and the concept of pheromones and
translate them to other real world
signals and how, for example,
communication patterns among other
animal entities or other human agents.
And I think that that opens up an
interesting perspective. And if you're
constantly trying to connect it back to
free energy minimization and trying to
say, well, how are we balancing the
terms that you can decompose it into an
epistemic and an instrumental, and how
are these balancing out and how are
these physical processes that we specify
balancing those terms? That's just a
very interesting place to be. And you
mentioned active inference versions of
Hans, and that's fascinating and of
itself. Last comment I have is, again,
the degree of modeling and what you are
modeling. Like, if you're modeling a
society or organization, that's one way.
You could use the ant colony framework,
if you will, or metaheuristic
optimization frameworks to then cast a
system, any type of complex multi agent
system, as an active inference kind of
engaging process. Or you could go really
low level and think about cells in a
body or units that make up organs or
organelles and trying to say, well, can
we use this to model that level of
granularity within, like a human or an
animal entity? Right? And I think
there's some fascinating questions about
how does this metaphor manifest itself
at different timescales and different
degrees of perspective about how you're
modeling? What are you looking at?
What's the picture that you want to
emulate? And of course, there's always
under the hood, this practical
consideration of, well, okay, the
computational expense that you allocate,
and are you able to actually run that
simulation long enough? Because I think
Abdul Rahman, you can correct me if I'm
wrong. You mentioned one of the
experiments I think was for the bigger
systems took a month. Right. Of course
this was on CPUs. That can get pretty
prohibitive if you want to go even
bigger than that. But again, I think it
just depends on what hardware you have
to simulate this on. Yeah.
And also using high performance
computing, it is not always feasible for
smaller. So if we try to model the brain
of Aims like small neural network,
using a GPU might not be feasible
solution. And Travis is a high
performance computing specialist here,
expert tell you that sending data
to a GPU and getting it back is very
time consuming and resources consuming.
So it will worsen the time
consumption rather than solving it,
because communicating between the main
memory and the GPU had an overhead.
So it has to be a big enough problem to
actually utilize this GPU in such
solutions.
Sorry, go ahead.
When you have the super large language
models, or large models for computer
vision, they do a lot of just massive
operations on Tensors, which are
basically multidimensional matrices,
right? And when you have really big wide
Tensors, you can parallelize the
operation really nicely across the GPU.
A lot of this work is based on doing
time series forecasting, time series
classification on sensor data, stuff
from like power systems. So the
input to a large language model might be
1000 or more length
of a word embedding, which is actually
not huge. But if you go up to a computer
vision model, the input image may be
1000 by 1000 pixels and that gives you
actually a million inputs. Right. When
you're working with sensor systems, off
of aircraft, power plants, that type of
thing, you may have 50 to 100 inputs.
And when you're working with this type
of time series data, you don't need a
massive super wide neural network. And
then if you add in recurrency where you
have to do backprop over time and other
things like this, you actually can't
really parallelize it nicely on a GPU.
So for us, the CPU is actually more
efficient. We tried Abdul Rahman wrote a
bunch of code a long time ago to put
this stuff on GPUs and we found it was
quite a bit slower. So, depending on
what you're doing with a neural network,
a GPU actually isn't the right answer.
But the other cool thing about this,
which I think does have maybe even
potential for there, is that one
of the big not talked about problems in
machine learning is that back
propagation is the fastest thing we
know, but it's inherently not scalable.
You can get a bigger, better GPU to do
your bits of your network in parallel to
speed things up, but that only gets
better if you have a bigger network. If
you want to speed up the training
process, you can't just add another CPU
or another GPU and make back prop go
faster. You can make the forward and
backward pass through your neural
network faster. But you still have to do
every epoch of backprop. Iteratively a
method like this where we're generating
one, it's backprop free. So it's not
using backprop. We can use a nature
inspired or other method to use hundreds
of computers and you can throw twice as
many computers at it and get a result
twice as back, twice as fast, whereas
backprop you can't do that. So if you
think about actually being able to train
a neural network backprop,
actually it's got a pretty low speed
limit for what we need to do. And it's
kind of a big problem with the machine
learning community that people don't
like to talk about because they're like
oh, I'll just buy the next big Nvidia
GPU and that'll do things faster.
That's super interesting. Does this
maybe even bring up a kind of
relationship where things like a
graphics visualization of course a GPU
does well and that's like the screen
changing through time with a classical
process that can be massively unfolded.
And then the cognitive models,
ultimately, of the nest mates, which
again, can be nested. But the thing
that's more quantum, more cognitive
model, like you can do in parallel,
because the minds are not influencing
each other except through stigma g. So
then that is CPU bound, the size of the
colony. And then you could use
different graphics techniques, like
there are colonies, organisms. So one
ant being or it's a philosophical
question. What is the scale at which A
exists? But all throughout California
with the Argentine ant, for example.
And so how do we deal with those kinds
of meshwork cognitive systems all the
way on through 50 in an Acorn?
There's just all these different trade
offs that are being made and like in the
featureless deserts there's different
wayfinding pathfinding sensor
integration, polarization of light,
like different cognitive strategies
because they might be going out long
distance and dragging something home,
not leaving any pheromone because it's
not any more likely to have food there.
So in that case, the stigma g is
basically minimal to essentially none.
And then in other situations you could
have something that's very adherent to
distributions to the point of being fit
to a very kind of normative
path. But that's happening at a level
that allows the different compute
architectures, different information
architectures and ultimately
different biological embodiments to
really engage fruitfully.
Again looking at the variability, the
diversity of biological algorithms for
collective behavior which have been
studied by Professor Gordon and others
in so many different angles. Yet
sometimes it can feel like multi agent
models always start kind of like at
square one, demonstrate some proof of
concept phenomena, and then that is
utilized as part of a bigger
perspective. But it's not like that
model was ever claimed to have been
tuned to maximum performance. It's like
well, we got decision making behavior.
You could transfer this to group
decision making with Honeybee decision
making or something like that, but
there's still a big gap there. But I
think what you're describing with the
Kant, which is funny because it could be
cannot, but also the Kant is the dialect
which is spoken. It was very funny when
we came up with it. Great choice.
And it's just like yeah, because there's
multiple perspectives to swap from on
the classical screen because the meaning
of the word is something that's
happening. That fourth dimension,
cognitively, the meaning of the word
isn't to be found just on the blanket,
just on the interface itself. That's
just the communication. And that's like
a bounded system. Then if you model a
cognitive system that doesn't have that
kind of a constraint, so represented by
a map that has some kind of blanket
index, some kind of blanketing if you
don't embody that constraint in the
statistical model, the map, you're
ignoring one of the fundamental
constraints of modeling the way
that things happen in an embodied
fashion. Maybe there's some abstract
space for a certain problem that's just
like a total slam dunk. However, for
full generality, at least to the space
that we know of, biological life forms
and their engagements and ecological
engagements, not just like within one
behavior, that space is so vast
and there's so much to learn across
different systems within two. Again, to
abduce away into different information
architectures and active inference being
some subset or type of those.
So it's awesome work. Do you have any
last comments?
Well, giving ability for brands to be
self aware and aware about its
environment is actually something that
we implemented in our last work
with the BP free camps. They are
indirectly aware about their environment
and they are adapting to the changes
in their clinical environment by
indirectly meaning that they are
evolving using a genetic based algorithm
to just change their behavior, like how
they sense the
hormones when they take the steps and
some other times or some other
characteristics they have. So they are
adapting, but kind of like not in
an intelligent way, but through
evolution. If you want to say,
actually, we considered putting a brain
in each one of these agents. But then
again, as Travis and
Alex mentioned, we found that it won't
be practical. Actually, it would hinder
our Asynchronous design
because we couldn't prolize that it will
take time to train each one of these
brains as we evolve the neural networks.
Awesome.
Alexander or Travis, any last thoughts?
Okay,
I'm just really happy. I mean, I think
this work is really interesting and it
opens up a lot of pretty cool avenues.
Again, if we can get to the point where
we're evolving colonies that are
producing ants and can see where that
can go. So one of the big issues in
neural architecture search is the whole
question of what is an optimal neural
network and what an optimal neural
network is. Could be different for what
will be different for different tasks.
But not only that, even if it's the same
data set, how you're using that neural
network could lead to a lesser, more
optimal neural network, right?
Depending on what you're doing with it,
maybe you need one that's more energy
efficient. Maybe you don't care about
energy efficiency or performance, and
you'll take a slower neural network,
but you need more accuracy. So being
able to have algorithms which can
automate this whole process for us and
tune them to what we actually want to
use the neural network for is really
important. And I think, one, just having
ant colony optimization be able to
optimize a network for a problem is
great. But two, if we can make it such
that the algorithm itself is self
optimizing, it really can streamline
this whole process where right now,
if you're doing machine learning, it can
be kind of miserable. You make a neural
network architecture, you try it out,
see how well it does. Oh no, that didn't
do so well. Let me tweak a couple of
knobs automating that process.
My whole life as a computer scientist is
about being lazy, but being smart about
it. So whatever I can optimize so that
I don't have to do it over and over
again seems like a good use of my time.
So I'll be smart about having to do as
little as possible in the future.
I don't have too much to add to that. I
think a lot of the good discussion has
happened already, and we talked about
various implications and ways of viewing
ant colony optimization from other
perspectives, including an active
inference point of view. So I guess
really more from a closing thought on my
end, is that it will be interesting, or
it is an interesting direction to think
about, like I said earlier or suggested,
about the adaptation of the metaphor to
other systems. And what are you trying
to model and what's your goals from a
scientific and philosophical point of
view? What are questions you seek to
answer? And I think it might be very
interesting, again, given other
developments and computing technology
and ways in which you implement. The
parallelization that, I think, is that's
what attracted me the most to a lot of
these meta heuristic algorithms, even
things like particle swarm. And when I
worked with Travis many years ago on the
exam algorithms, you saw our names on
that and working on that type of stuff.
The part that always caught my attention
is, again, that ability to say, I can
put these entities on different
processing, computing, processing
resources or devices, and then they will
interact and exchange their results in
some way to try to optimize some often
complex multi objective cost function.
And so I think the part that we'll see
or that would encourage the wider spread
adoption of even like meta heuristic
algorithms in general, not to say that
they aren't used a lot in, for example,
the engineering domains is again the
development of parallel computing
processing systems and I think
exploiting things like asynchronous
computing. That was again another angle
that caught my attention from Travis.
He's done a lot of work on genetic
optimization and neurovolution from an
asynchronous point of view. And how can
we allocate, whatever resources are
available and distributing them across
global networks? I think that might be
the best shot to scaling up, let's say,
with what we got right now. There might
be again, you've mentioned, Daniel,
quantum technology. Quantum computing is
another interesting place that sort of
like changes the barring
technologies that we don't necessarily
have exactly at their best at this
moment. How can we take advantage of
citizen science or distributed computing
or peer to peer type of communication
and building massive active inference
systems that embody like the multi agent
metaphor of ant colony optimization or
other nature inspired frameworks? And
can this system evolve over very
long spans of time, just like evolution
really worked? Another piece, my final
comp and is that why I'm interested
sometimes in evolution is that to
me it is the inductive bias that
provided us with structures that allow,
for example, a human agent. Babies can
to operate already. Babies can already
recognize faces, right? And we have
certain instinctual reactions and
certain mechanisms that evolution has
endowed us with. And so a fascinating
question is what is the interplay of the
idea of simulating an artificial form of
evolution? Maybe building DNA structures
or very simplified computational
structures? Which would answer Abdel
Rahman's concern about, well, maybe we
don't want the agents to be too smart in
of themselves because I can't really
simulate that unless you give me like a
decade to run the simulator. But you
could maybe come up with a more
fundamental primitive and then use that
as a starting point for your neural
network. Let's say, Daniel, you want to
do some task in image segmentation and
like okay, but what can your
evolutionary framework give me? Well,
I'll say here here's a template to start
from. This is a kernel on which you
build your framework and it's like a DNA
structure. And this has evolved across
many years of distributed peer to peer
computing. And you could imagine
building this mammoth evolving,
continual learning style evolutionary
algorithm, whether it is based on
genetic algorithms or ant colony. And
you could imagine that might be an
interesting way to think about. And by
the way, I am spitballing and generating
an idea of how I could envision a
scalable form without inventing a new
computing system that I don't know will
or will not exist because quantum has a
lot of problems still to solve too,
like superconducting or super
temperatures or trapping photons,
as I have learned. So that might be an
interesting direction. I think the
scaling of this, especially from the
practical end, is going to be the most
important. We're going to. Need to pull
together all the tools that we have, as
I mentioned before. So I'll stop there,
too, because I'll let Abraham blame
more, so hopefully that made sense.
Well, this was very epic and inspiring,
so good luck with the work. You're all
welcome to suggest another piece
that we might focus on or continue the
discussion however you see fit, because
it's super interesting direction. So
thank you. Till next time. Thank you.
Thank you so much.